ce sera leur 28e salon de l'agriculture
la ferme de viltain comme chaque année
il présentera produits et bétail avec un
troupeau de 350 têtes la ferme possède
le deuxième cheptel de france cette
année normalement devrait avoir deux ou
trois petits veaux notamment un de cette
couleur là et en cette couleur là encore
on a une
un petit veau qui a une couleur marron
c'est la même race da prim'holstein
l'idée c'est que voilà on a des gènes de
temps en temps des petites surprises des
bonnes surprises comme celle là avec
avec des jolies vos marron leurs
troupeaux produit 3 5 millions de litres
de lait par an la ferme de viltain on
transforme 30% au fromage blanc lait de
consommation et un yaourt en octobre
dernier l'entreprise familiale se dote
d'une nouvelle laiterie elle souhaite
atteindre le million de yaourt par an en
fonction des clients on peut avoir un
client qui va avoir quatre cuisines
centrales en ile de france
on va toucher 150 communes je savais que
ce client là on va avoir en litres de
lait
jusqu'à 9000 litres qui passent dans la
laiterie à la journée ça c'est un
objectif qu'on s'est fixés dans le
développement de la laiterie
donc il est pas encore atteint
évidemment mais ça peut être ça peut
être un pic qui attend en fonction des
gens ces produits vendus au marché de la
ferme seront présentés à la porte de
versailles le salon de l'agriculture est
un moyen pour eux de se faire connaître
du particulier comme du professionnel
pour nous c'est une grande force
on va avoir une visibilité qui est très
grande on accueille des milliers de
spectacteurs sur notre sur notre stand
soit par la vente de produits locaux
donc nos produits soit par des petits
jeux qui sont sur place la ferme de
viltain sera parmi le millier
d'exposants présents sur le salon
celui ci ouvre ses portes le samedi 27
février
les vo vous attendent jusqu'au dimanche
6 mars